I think the the interesting thing one of
one of the most interesting things of
the book was when you talked about going
from what was it a Forman four person
company well it started me and another
guy and yeah three people three okay and
how many 1500 1500 um the transformation
of that and and your role in that um
from being an investor to being a
manager to all the other things in
between so for My Success it was uh
related ship of meaningful work and
meaningful
relationships but from a time management
standpoint Ray when you spent your time
trying to find the right Investments
trying to find the way right way to
manage and maximize the returns to being
responsible for 1500 employees right you
there's no way you could spend the same
amount of time managing you know the
actual dollars as managing the people
when you start and you know it's two or
three people and then you go to another
level you I had to invent a new way a
new way a new way I remember when we got
to 67 people that I would always give uh
personalized gifts at the holiday season
and I would always write everybody a
long letter at the holiday season and I
remember it was 67 people and I remember
I couldn't do it right because it broke
my back I mean just too much and then I
and I knew that I was now going to
another level and when I was going to
that other level I had to invent a new
way of operating so going from the three
to the 1500 required a lot of different
invent
inventiveness